good afternoon I'd like to introduce
myself first my name is Jim Levinson I'm
the director of the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs here at Yale I'm
delighted to see everybody welcome I
have the privilege of introducing David
Brooks but if you don't know who he is
you're probably in the wrong room
David David occupies a position of great
intellectual influence one of those jobs
where when people agree with you they
think you're a genius
and when they don't agree with you you
know not so much and that job of course
is as a faculty member here at Yale
David is teaching two courses this
semester he's in the Grady Johnson grand
strategy program where he teaches the in
the grand strategy class and he's also
teaching a seminar here at the Jackson
Institute for which were very very
grateful on the side he writes for The
New York Times and he chats it up on PBS
newshour
with with Mark shields the format today
David will speak for about 40 minutes
there abouts and then we'll do Q&A this
is advertised as a Jackson town hall
meeting and the usual format is first of
some some remarks and then a
conversation so I'll hand it off
thank you Jim I'm very impressed to be
in this August room I'm curious to know
how they write on the top board up there
very long arms here at Yale and it's
it's it's been a thrill to be back at
the University of my parents were
academics and so it's sort of the family
business being a left-wing academic is
actually the family business my father
was teaching at NYU in the 60s when I
was five years old and he took me to a
be in where hippies would go just to be
and so I was five and I I saw them at
the bee and they said a garbage can on
fire and threw their wallets into it to
demonstrate their liberation from money
and material things and I was five and I
saw a five dollar bill floating in the
on fire in the garbage can so I broke
from the crowd put my hand in the fire
grabbed the money and ran away and that
was my first step over to the right but
and I guess along with that I I stepped
away from academia the family business
and I became a conservative columnist at
the New York Times which I liken to
being the chief rabbi at Mecca not
always a lot of company there but it's
been a delight and exceeded all my
pleasure to be back here at Yale and now
I will try to be brief I've been to Yale
I've taught here before and I know you
didn't come here to hear me speak you
came here to hear yourself speak and so
I'll try to let you get away with that
but it's been a huge pleasure to be back
in this community I taught here about 12
or 13 years ago and I I maintained to
this day that Yale is still one of the
best 250 universities in the state of
Connecticut I myself went to the best
university in the country the University
Chicago the which is a Baptist School
where atheist professors teach Jewish
students st. Thomas Aquinas
and but still slumming it here isn't too
bad and actually what's striking about
this place is first the thing that's the
same as from 12 years ago is I remain
convinced that Yale students are the
most argumentative students in the
country and I mean that is complement
it's true the big two changes since I
was here last time one much more
international student body just feels
much more international and it's sort of
striking the second much more cross
pollenization with my other world more
relationships for the first time I came
here I felt really coming from
Washington to New Haven was entering a
world with some conversation between the
two but now it just feels like there's
much more and so to me this is a cross
polarization between one world this one
which is an intellectual world and the
world I normally inhabit in Washington
which is a tactile world if you hang
around politicians you know they can't
just talk to you they don't much to say
but they do touch you
and so they rub your hair they grab the
back your head they stand too close to
you they invade your personal space
they had what I call logorrhea dementia
which is they talk so much as drives
themselves insane and they have the
incredible human contact the story I
tell which you'll call name-dropping
what I call reporting is I was in Aspen
Colorado getting in touch with the real
America and I was walking down the
street and I see Bill Clinton and he's
watching a High School Jazz Band
so I go up to him we say hi and since
he's Clinton he can't just tell me about
the saxophonist in the jazz band he has
to touch me and sort of grope the need
and you know just be all over and so in
the course of three songs since he's him
and I'm me we move about 40 yards and
that directions of me powering
so that's that tactile world actually
once was at NIH I saw a video of a young
girl with Williams syndrome and Williams
syndrome is like reverse autism kids
have no interest in material objects
intense social connection they stand
like 18 inches away and just stare into
people's eyes and I saw this video of
this little girl and I'm thinking this
is every senator I've ever covered they
all like them and so to see the cross
pollenization between that world and
this one has been enormous ly rewarding
and I think the chorus Paula's a ssin
the internationalism of the student body
and the cross pollenization are in part
a larger result of both the Jackson
Institute and the grant strategy project
and it's just an honor to be part of
those two so I'm gonna try to talk about
this cross pollenization this world
Accela world between these two the spot
where intellectual traditions moral
conduct and practical politics intersect
and this is more or less what Plutarch
was doing back in the day doing in the
form of biography in the form of people
and especially doing it in the form of
exemplars exemplars who embody certain
values who people can study and and
imitate and so I would say the this
question of of exemplars who would Lou
talk would write about who were the
character exemplars of our a day or at
least of modern history and how do we
think about moral codes sort of
percolated in my mind starting a few
years ago and so I was riding driving
home on a Sunday night a couple years
ago and on Sunday nights in Washington
NPR report class old radio shows and I
happen to hear a show called command
performance which was a variety show
that went out to the troops in World War
two and I happened to hear the episode
that was broadcast live on VJ Day
just hours after the Japanese had
announced they would surrender and all
the big stars were on the show Cary
Grant Marlena Dietrich Lionel Barrymore
Jimmy Durante the host of the show has
been Crosby Bing Crosby gets out and
said we've just learned that we've won
the war I guess we don't feel too proud
he says I guess we're just glad we got
through it
and then he says today though our deep
down feeling is one of humility so it's
been five years of bloody war and he
comes out there with this incredibly
modest tone and so I was sort of struck
by this and it happens repeatedly
throughout the project and so about half
an hour another program burgess meredith
gets out there and he reads a passage
from the world correspondent Ernie Pyle
who would actually died recently
but Pyle had anticipated the moment and
he'd written this and Meredith reads it
we won this war because our men are
brave and because of many other things
because of Russia England and China in
the passage of time and the gift of
nature's materials we did not win it
because destiny created us better than
all other people and I hope that in
victory victory we are more grateful
than proud and again tone of modesty so
I listen I stay in the driveway you
listen to the end and it's online if you
want to hear this show I turn on the TV
watch a football game quarterback throws
a pass to a wide receiver the wide
receiver catches it and is tackled after
a two yard gain and the cornerback the
defensive player does what all
professional athletes do have after
moments of supreme personal achievement
he does a victory dance in honor of
himself and so it occurred to me I've
seen a bigger self puffing victory dance
after a two yard game then I had heard
after winning World War two and so this
little episode symbolized to me a slight
shift in culture morale culture from a
culture of self-effacement which says
I'm no better anybody else but nobody's
better than me to a culture of self
advancement or self-expression and some
of this is just in the manners so if you
talk about the the people who you know
some of it just you know what's polite
and what's not polite so Bob Hope once
joked that when he started his career
you could tell every ethnic joke you
wanted but no sexual jokes
now when the end is career you could
tell all the sexual jokes you wanted and
no ethnic jokes in 1945 you could buy
the cigarettes out in the front of the
drugstore but you had to go behind the
counter to get the condoms now you buy
the condoms in front you have to go
behind the kind of guys cigarettes so
certain things just change
and so if you look back in the days of
the command performance certain things
are just more modest so people still
wore suits to baseball games there were
hats everywhere there was codes of
reticence Joe Friday Gary Cooper there
was less self-expression
there was known nudity in the media
there were no exclamation points
I'm the typewriter keypads there were no
college window stickers on the back of
people's cars there were no vanity
license plates there were no message
t-shirts
there were 23 men and women who served
in Dwight Eisenhower's cabinet one wrote
a memoir Reagan's cabinet 30 served well
over half row memoirs so there's just a
shift some of it is just manners but as
I thought about it more I thought
there's the shift to self expression is
a little more than just manners it's a
shift in moral attitudes and if you want
to think about it most carefully or more
simplistically there are two sort of
traditions that are relevant here one is
a tradition that says I distrust myself
but I trust things outside myself like
codes like God's law or I trust myself
and I distrust things outside myself
like social conventions and so these are
sort of two traditions and I would say
now we're living with the latter I trust
myself and distrust things outside
myself and so if you go to a
commencement address even at places like
this the cliches are be true to yourself
follow your passion Ellen DeGeneres told
a group of Tulane my advice is be true
to yourself and everything will be fine
Anna Quindlen told the college
graduation class honor your character
your intellect your inclinations in your
soul listening to it's clean clear voice
instead of following the modeled
messages of a timid world look inside
and you can see it in the moral
searching that we do today our most
popular moral book in recent times was
Elisabeth Gilbert's eat Pray Love
Gilbert writes you have the right to
cherry-pick when it comes to moving your
spirit and finding your peace you take
whatever works for you wherever you can
find it and you keep moving toward
lay God Gilbert writes is my own voice
from within my own self God dwells
within me as me myself exactly what I am
that's a high level of self Trust
paradigmatic book of this era is a book
by dr. Seuss the places you'll go which
sat atop the New York Times bestseller
list 478 weeks and it starts you have
brains in your head you have feet in
your shoes you can steer yourself any
direction you choose the word you
appears 90 times in that little book and
so it's you can go anywhere you want you
are your lone life project and that's
sort of the project of the meritocracy
to get in places like this self
development and has a great side some
creativity unleashing of energy I'd say
it has some downsides in 1950 the Gallup
Organization as high school seniors are
you a very important person and 19 1950
12% said yes
they asked the same question 2005 and it
wasn't 12% it was 80% they do these
narcissism tests they give people
comments and they say does this apply to
you and the comments include things like
I'd like to be the center of attention
I find that easy to manipulate people
somebody should write a biography about
me the median narcissism scores risen by
30% in two decades and so along with
that has become a tremendous desire for
fame which is now one of the top desires
for young people I saw a study they
asked high school or college students I
guess this was high school students
would you rather be a personnal a
celebrity's personal assistant Justin
Bieber's personal assistant or president
of Harvard and of course three two one
they'd rather be Justin Bieber's
personal assistant though I asked the
president Harvard and she would rather
be Justin Bieber's roses
and so that's the ethos of that's more
common today but there is an ethos that
I think was more common in the command
performance day that distrust yourself
and I just tried to collect some of the
components of that ethos and so they
would be I'll just list them out of
things that we're probably more common
in the culture there than they are now
one that human beings are divided broken
creatures were problems to ourselves we
want things we should not want we want
to do one thing we end up doing another
- the central theme of our weaknesses
that we're self-centered we tend to
inflate our own interests we rationalize
our own weaknesses we put our interest
into fret of others three pride is the
central vais pride is what blinds you to
the reality of your own divided nature
and your own brokenness for humility is
the central virtue humility is having an
accurate assessment of your own
weaknesses humility is having an
awareness that you're an underdog and
the struggle against your own weaknesses
humility means understanding you're an
underdog in the completing the task
that's been assigned to you
fifth that the struggle against sin and
weakness is a central drama in life
that nothing that happens outside your
life is as important and as dramatic and
it's creative as a struggle against your
weakness inside your life six that
character is nothing more or less than
your way of waging this internal
campaign the strategies you use what you
strengthen what you weaken seventh that
no person can achieve self mastery on
his or her own every one individual will
individual reason are not strong enough
to combat against the weakness and so
everyone is reliant on something outside
themselves whether an eternal code the
redemptive love of God friends rules
traditions disciplines eighth that
defeating weakness often means quieting
the self quieting the self so you can
realize the external resources you need
to tap into quieting the self so you can
see yourself you can see reality
unfiltered quieting myself so you can
react with that
boys to the struggles ninth that
defeating weakness means finding a coat
outside yourself and this is a code that
can be religious but it can also be
professional the code of the
intellectual the code of the worker that
quoted the truck-driver the code of the
private eye there's a great Daniel how I
say Erving how excuse me on the code of
the intellectual I saw in partisan
review in the 50s and he writes at that
poem some writers these days have fallen
so low they will write for The New
Yorker and worse far worse and in those
days writing for New Yorker was
violating the code that was going to pop
10th you don't choose your social
function Viktor Frankl getting out of a
concentration camp at about the time of
command performance says it's not what
you ask of life it's what life is asking
of you you were assigned a job by fate
or by God and then finally 11th or an
ultimately 11th that the campaign
against weakness is often an ironical
campaign you can only save yourself by
losing yourself you have to admit
weakness in order to build strength
success often leads to failure and
failure often leads to success and then
finally that the best social
arrangements take a count of The Crooked
Timber of humanity that the highest
public virtue is moderation political
conflicts are rarely a contest between
good and evil but are usually contest
between two partial truths and so these
are sort of a collection of of things
that I think were more common beliefs
that were more common in the culture and
when you look back at the days of
command performance and when people
wrote about character the word character
I think really doesn't have much meaning
outside that concept of internal combat
once you take that concept of internal
combat away the word character sort of
dissolves second the thing they talked
about much more than now as a concrete
awareness of this little word sin which
was I think more alive than than now and
third I think you can find exemplary
characters who sort of embody bits of
this little code I've just quickly
described so the guy who was running
European troops at the time of command
performance obviously was Dwight
Eisenhower
now Eisenhower when he was 10 back in
Abilene wanted to go out
trick-or-treating and his mom wouldn't
let him and I Eisenhower little
Eisenhower through with temper tantrum
and punched the tree in his front yard
and he punched it so much that all the
skin was worn off his knuckles and mom
sent him up to his room for an hour to
cry and that complete his temper tantrum
she finally gets up there and she binds
his wounds and she says to him a verse
he that conquer his own soul is greater
than he who taketh the city this idea of
self combat and 76 years later
Eisenhower wrote in his memoir I've
always looked up back upon that
conversation as one of the most valuable
moments of my life the idea that he
would have to conquer his problems in
his case his anger which was something
he did struggle with through life and
that involved I think in Ike's case a
great degree of lifelong self repression
and so he had the same rank of major for
16 years in the Army no promotions his
brothers are rising through the world
he's just stuck but he becomes a servant
to the code of being a soldier well we
would today call an organization man he
gets on a base and at one point he
writes when I go to a new station I look
to see who is the strongest and ableist
man on the post I forget my own ideas
and do everything in my power to remote
what he says is right that is the
definition of a need of an organization
man and that sort of embodies embodied I
think in the way fights World War two
serving the duties of balance and then
as president and to me one of my
favorite moments of ICA's happens at the
end of his term on in January 20th 1961
Kennedy gives this inauguration address
the s not address which is bold and
utopian and inspiring Kennedy says man
holds in his power the ability to Bala
SH all forms of human poverty we can
explore the Stars conquer disease
deserts eradicate disease its absolutist
in in its ambition three days before
Eisenhower has given his farewell speech
it's an entirely different mode
it's all about balance we got to balance
this against that we have to suspect
ourselves we have to suspect
concentrated bigness we have to suspect
concentrations of power one is only
ambitious in utopian the other is
representing a different ethos of
modesty
so that's Eisenhower his superior man
running off u.s. forces with George C
Marshall he embodies a little different
part of the code which is rectitude a
man of intense dignity and an intense
personal self-discipline two favorite
episodes or two episodes from Marshalls
life none of them particularly happy but
emphasizing his own rectitude one
happened in 1927 when his wife Lily who
was then 53 was ill with a heart
condition
Marshalls teaching in the War College
and he gets a call while he's lecturing
and so he goes into a little room to
take the call and the soldier who's
accompanying him sees him put his head
down on his desk and the soldier says is
there something I can do general and he
Marshall responds quote no mr.
Throckmorton I just had word that my
wife who was to join me here today has
just died and so even at this moment of
incredible trauma there was the careful
diction that remembering the fellows
name Marshall is not particularly good
with names
to self control and self possession the
other a more famous moment happens in
the middle of World War two he wants to
run Operation Overlord and at various
moments Churchill and Stalin tell him
he's going to get this job running the
d-day invasion and he badly wants it and
so Roosevelt sends Harry Hopkins out to
sound them about the job and then
Roosevelt finally calls him into the
Oval Office and says would you like to
run Operation Overlord but Marshall has
a code of no self promotion and so he
says the president in effect my personal
emotions don't really matter here do
whatever you think is best for you and
Roosevelt asked and repeatedly and
repeatedly Marshall says no Roosevelt
takes the chance to give the job to
Eisenhower
sporting Marshalls ambitions which hurt
him in this case to that reticent code
at service code is what make him
probably the most revered figure of the
time so these are sort of two white
highborn people exemplifying this code
but you don't have to stick with the the
elites the leading civil rights figure
in this day is a guy named philip
randolph a philip randolph philip
randolph grew up around Jacksonville
Florida who's a Shakespearean actor as a
young man and was famous for his code of
dignity Ciel dellums a colleague and
labor organizer said of him
Randolph learned to sit erect and walk
erect you almost never saw him leaning
back reclining no matter how enjoyable
the occasion he looked and there's
Randolph just as straight as he as if
they were a board in his back and no
matter what people did to try to
humiliate him he superseded them with
his own dignity he was impossible to
humiliate the man and though he was
politically extremely radical but super
but in matters of morals and personality
extremely popped ileus again
self-restraint his purpose Shea was a
guy named Bayard Rustin the extremely
interesting figure who sat out about the
time of command performance he was in
jail as a pacifist
he was an objector and he was serving
the cause in jail as sort of a
troublesome prisoner but he had a
weakness which was he was promiscuous
with the other men in the prison it was
finally brought to his attention that
his promiscuity was hurting the cause of
pacifism and he wrote a letter to his
mentor which I'll read a part of when
success was imminent in our racial
campaign my behavior stopped progress
I've misused the confidence the Negroes
here had in my leadership I've caused
them to question the moral basis of
non-violence I have heard and let down
my friends I'm a traitor by our means of
thought just as surely as an army
captain who willfully exposed military
positions during a battle I have
dedicated my life to ego I have thought
in terms of my own power my own time
my own energy I thought of my ability my
willingness I have not humbly accepted
God's gifts and this is led I now see
first to arrogance then to pride then to
weakness and then to artificiality and
failure and so this is an embrace of a
old fashioned corrective and Rustin
spends much of the next years of his
life in the background of the civil
rights movement but ultimately
organizing the march on Washington and
speaking in that March another pacifist
at that time is Dorothy Day Dorothy Day
represents another aspect of this and I
highly recommend students read her book
the long loneliness because if you want
to know the drama the inner drama of the
life of self combat she captures it
perfectly that the intensity of her
struggle and she it's fascinating to
read her as she's reading Dostoevsky
she's reading dusty husky as if her life
depends on it and it's really an intense
inner struggle but her great gift was
self criticism relentless and
remorseless self criticism as a way to
build herself her strengths up and all
through life you see her the high school
student you see her in college which is
a brief career as a bohemian radical
writer incredibly self-critical always
finding herself wanting and improving
better and at one point she's arrested
she goes into a hotel to help some
Wobblies the hotel is raided and she's
picked up as if she were a prostitute
and she could say well this was wrongful
arrests the cops are awful she says this
was long flu arrests the cops were awful
but I realized that I myself have been
motivated by things unworthy and she
writes in the course of that arrest I do
not think that ever again no matter of
what I am accused can I suffer more than
I did then of shame and regret and
self-contempt not only because I had
been caught found out branded publicly
humiliated but because of my own
consciousness that I deserved it and so
for her the redemption comes in the form
of service to God but especially in
service to a covenant
community and the final person I'll talk
about a little longer is a someone I've
come to greatly admire who's the first
labor secretary or the first female
secretary of cabinet which was Frances
Perkins Frances Perkins is born April
10th 1880
sort of a highborn but not particularly
rich family in Maine her ancestors
included James Otis who was a
Revolutionary War hero Oliver Otis
Howard is a Civil War general and hero
and who founded Howard University she
grew up in a pretty traditional starchy
New England family she grew up reading
Greek poetry recited Greek plays she
once came down for a dance in her
teenage years and her father cracked and
told her that she looked ladylike which
by his standards was an effusion of
emotion and so she later wrote even if I
had succeeded in making myself look
pretty which mind you I'm not saying
that I ever did my father would never
have told me that would have been a sin
she goes off to Mount Holyoke and she is
surrounded by external rules college
students here should know that in Mount
Holyoke in 1902 freshmen should quote
keep respectful silence in the presence
of sophomores freshmen meeting a
sophomore on campus should show
respectful should bow respectfully no
freshmen shall wear a long skirt or high
hair before the mid-year examinations of
codes she her teachers were interested
in our academic development but more
interested in her moral development and
so they decided she Frances Perkins had
the ability to try to skate by on her
verbal abilities so she wanted to major
in English and they said no you're gonna
major in what you're bad at you're gonna
be a science major and so she was a
chemistry major and they said that'll
toughen you up man Holyoke in those days
was a remarkable school it was infused
with the feeling of the social gospel
with their saying was do what nobody
else wants to do go where nobody else
wants to go and so even in this time
1902
they're sending young women out to
middle of China middle of Africa
incredibly brave in far-flung places
mostly to do missionary work Francis
Perkins
ends up going to Chicago she ends up
working with Jane Adams at Hull House
for a little while and then she comes
back to New York and on March 25th 1911
she's having tea in one of the
brownstones at the north end of
Washington Square Park and she's having
tea with a woman who's who also had a an
ancestor sign who signed the Declaration
and they hear a commotion outside and
they rush outside and they see just off
the square of fire and it turns out
they've stumbled on the Triangle
Shirtwaist Factory fire so they run out
to the fire and if you standing on Mount
Washington Square looking south it's
sort of in the streets it's now NYU
just about half block down and so
they're rushing up to the buildings and
they see what they think are people the
fire is on the 8th 9th and 10th floor
the top floors and they see what they
think people are throwing bundles of
clothing out of the windows but it turns
out it's not funnels of clothing it's
people leaping to their deaths to avoid
the fire sort of like after 9/11 so the
fire is just spreading they just want to
get out they'd rather die and so she
comes up and they're screaming up don't
jump don't jump
but it's futile when they jump the
firemen are holding up these blankets
but the bodies just ripped straight
through and I think she sees about 48
people jump and die this way one person
a lady gives a speech with her arms
gesticulating and then leaps and nobody
can hear a word she says
another case there's a young man who's
helping the ladies across the windowsill
and daintily hanging them out and then
dropping them so one two three four and
the fourth one is a girlfriend or
something he gives her a long kiss a
long embrace he drops her and then he
himself goes over and so she watches
this and is rededicated in her career of
service and becomes an instrument in the
Sur
this of worker safety she contacts our
Smith goes to Albany as a lobbyist for
worker safety she realizes the
progressives who are her natural allies
all they want is perfection
so she aligns herself with the Machine
the Tama Nihal machine because these
guys are sleazy but they'll give her at
least half a loaf second she realizes
that she's in her upper 20s maybe at
this point and it's the 1920s actually
earlier and they won't take her
seriously but she had she keeps a a
folder which she calls notes on the male
mind and in this folder she makes a
notation that everybody every man loves
his mother and so she says if I remind
them of my mother they'll listen to me
so she dresses up like a 75 year old
woman she wears these frumpy dresses
pearl necklace tri-corner hat different
haircut and gets the nickname mother
Perkins even though she's 27 and sort of
sacrifices her youth to get taken
seriously and she's successful they
passed serious legislation and then
she's hired by Franklin Roosevelt when
he becomes president she of course says
I don't want the job but it turns out
she's one of the few people who stays
with Roosevelt through his entire term
until the end of World War two she had
thought very little of Roosevelt when
she saw him in Albany but later running
for president she she saw him struggling
with polio gripping the podiums in his
hands would shake and she said this made
him a better human being and so she came
to work for him but alone of his admired
advisors and I highly recommend reading
a book she wrote called the Roosevelt I
knew one of the canny ascriptions of
them she understood the essential
quality that she had to worry about
which was that he was slippery he would
tell one thing to her something else to
somebody else and so she devised a
strategy to deal with this problem she
would come in to him with a meeting with
four options for him to choose listed on
this memo paper
she would ask him what she wanted she
would make him repeat it she would make
him initial it she would ask him again
so he couldn't back out and so this is a
bit of the can eNOS and if she would say
is that all right is that okay
you sure you sure and she would nail him
down she was not a popular member of the
cabinet she was not popular with the
press because even though she was the
first woman in the cabinet and therefore
likely to be a big deal
she was reticent she didn't want to talk
about her own personal life and so the
press sort of turned on her she was not
particularly popular with their
colleagues in 1939 J Parnell Thomas of
New Jersey introduced impeachment
hearings against her on the grounds that
she was aiding communists and the charge
was bogus but everybody had abandoned
her and she was Roosevelt had the chance
to defend beary decide not to the
women's group said not to they just
didn't want to get in Thomas's way and
so she had to do it all alone strict
code of self control she wrote at one
point of course if I wept at all or let
myself down I would have disintegrated
that's the kind of person which we New
Englanders are we disintegrate if we do
these things and so she kept herself
strong she won that battle she did not
she finally in 1945 got to leave
government when Roosevelt's death went
back to her personal life which was not
a happy one her husband went insane her
daughter also suffered severe mental
problems and in many ways had the
happiest moment of her life when she was
asked to teach a Cornell she was alone
she was taking buses around giving
speeches at this point and she's giving
lectures at Cornell and she's staying a
little hotel and somebody decides that
she shouldn't stay in a hotel she should
go live with some students and so the
students of a place called Telluride
house call and ask her to live with them
and she wrote at that point she felt
like a bride on her wedding night she
got to live with all these young men she
lived directly next to the master of the
house a guy named Alan bloom who then
wrote the closing of the American mind
she became close with all the
students and one of her pallbearers was
a student named Paul Wolfowitz it's a
little irony of history now I tell all
these stories not because I would want
to go back to the 1950s or the 1940s
when you look at this period you see a
obviously sexist racist anti-semitic
very few of us would want to go back to
it second boring the food was boring
culture had some pluses and minuses but
one of the things you also see is how
emotionally starved it was especially
the relationships between fathers and
sons and daughters very emotionally
starved in general and so I don't say
this we should ever go back but if
you've got these two moral traditions
one that distrust the self and trusts
institutions and one that trusts itself
and distress institutions we've probably
heard a little too far over on one side
and so I only tell these stories because
I think if Plutarch was alive he'd want
exemplars of the virtues that we need to
recover and in the culture we have today
which has a fair degree of self approval
having retrieving some of that rival
tradition would probably be a good thing
so thank you very much
now if anybody wants to ask about
sequestration happy to do that
Steven Pinker spoke here a few months
ago you know as thesis is that violence
is decreasing and I asked him about
violence decreasing but all of us
internalizing the you know because we're
losing our autonomy because of the
government you know we give up our
rights you know and he says the violence
decreases because the government is you
know over overseeing us but I also asked
him are we starting to internalize and
repress all this lack of autonomy mental
illnesses is greater 500 murders in
Chicago and so forth can you morality is
a very difficult subject can you comment
on I don't know if you know anything
about what Pinker was talking about but
could you bet just give some comments
about yeah so I know both their books
reasonably well and I guess one thing I
would say is a I I'm totally convinced
by their argument that violence is
decreasing first over the long term one
of the problems in the tribal societies
they didn't have certify us battles like
we did but they had trouble stopping in
the revenge cycles and so there was long
periods of just low-level violence so if
you look at say German and Japanese
fatality rates in the 20th century which
are reasonably high they're still lower
than your average tribal society that
Jared Diamond talks about so that's over
the centuries it's also true and so the
immoral culture doesn't just go in one
direction you know depravity improvement
you know it's complicated and so some of
things were good at are heading in the
right direction so and I think this is
largely true of college students or
people under 30 it's incredibly
wholesome and responsible generation so
violence is down by
while violent crime is down by 70%
regular crime down by 50%
teenage pregnancy is down by about a
third of Worsham rates are down by a
third drug violence is down suicide
rates are down incredibly wholesome and
responsible generation I think they're
all gonna have the biggest midlife
crisis in human history in about 10
years
but until then very responsible even
diverse rates are coming down so that
part is fine I do think the rise of what
I described as this self approval does
contribute to other problems and so
those would be things like rising
consumption on yourself a rising sense
I'm pretty special I should spend on
myself personal debt as a presenter GDP
is about 40 percent for about the first
seven decades of the 20th century it
shoots up two hundred and thirty three
percent seem leanness CEOs in the 1950s
60s and 70s were worth a lot to their
companies but none of them wanted to be
paid as much as a million dollars a year
because it would violate the code of
seem leanness they have overcome that
problem
polarization if you have a modest sense
of your own position your own the truth
of your own position you need the people
on the other side who disagree with you
to balance off your own weakness if you
think you have the truth by the short
hairs you don't need the other side and
then finally and I would say there's
been a loss of moral articulate us and
Christian Smith a scientist and a social
scientist at Notre Dame went around the
college campus is asking college
students name a moral dilemma what was
your last moral dilemma and two-thirds
could name a moral dilemma so they'd say
well I pulled into a parking space but
in enough quarters they'd say well
that's a problem it's not really a moral
dilemma and his explanation which I
share is that we've told a couple
generations including mine come up with
your own values find your own philosophy
and if your name is Aristotle that's
fine you can probably do that if it's
not our style you probably have some
difficulties and you'll resort back to
what alasdair macintyre calls emotivism
what feels right for me is good for me
what feels right for you is good for you
and who are we to judge each other and
so I think the culture is basically
healthy but with some problems and as
for the role of government one of the
reasons I'm up here is because when you
think about the realm of influence of
the world of how we influence each other
I would say politics is like over here
and culture and ideas are over here it's
just a bigger scope of influence and we
talked about this in my class today who
was more powerful Pericles or Thucydides
who had a bigger effect on the world
that's a very debatable point I think
through cities probably did the guy who
just observed and described and so I do
think most of the pluses and minuses of
culture are not affected by legislation
they're affected by ideas that come out
of places like this that's a long answer
of mine next answer will not be that
long
that I would try a liberal but you are
my favorite Republican is can I ask
who's number two you know the column
that was published yesterday I agree
100% with you on that the question I
have is what is the likelihood that
someone on either side has 0 I'm
thinking backwards say no you know so I
would say I've had this conversation
with various leaders including the
president and one of the things that
they have is in a sense that they can't
do anything alone
so they when they step out for a policy
there have to be institutions to support
them and or else and you can see in
their eyes you'd see in Obama his spider
senses start tingling there's danger
here if I do something that sort of goes
against what the institutional base of
the Democratic Party wants
I feel the danger and I'm gonna retreat
back the same God knows the same thing
for Republican politicians and so one of
the things that I think is true of
society now is that the left has a lot
of institutions a lot of donors and a
lot of ideas the right has a lot of
donors a lot of institutions and some
ideas and not as much as I would hope
but ideas but the center has no
institutions no donors and no ideas if
you go to a liberal dinner in Washington
a lot of academics and think tankers if
you go to a conservative dinner there
are a lot of academics and think tankers
you go to a moderate dinner it's just a
bunch of lobbyists and so the the
intellectual substructure isn't there
and so I think the intellectual
substructure can be built if you take
1/2 of Edinburgh and 1/2 out of
Alexander Hamilton that's sort of what I
try to do but but it's not there so it's
hard for them to be there and the people
who start out agreeing with people like
me like John McCain you nor I think like
Obama they go to where the institutions
are following their natural
instincts well the last couple of
decades this country spend enormous
amount of money trying to improve the
scores of inner-city schools the results
of that terrible money's been spent
there's no change and the reason often
given is the decay of the family family
life well I do think that is the core
problem I think one of the reasons the
heart of inequality in the heart of
intergenerational transmission of
inequality is what Jim Heckman at
Chicago calls non-cognitive skills which
is things like attachment does a kid
grow up in an atmosphere where they
learn how to attach teachers at others
and that's formed as early as eighteen
months self-control formed at 14 months
lack of stress there's a famous study
the ACE study where they looked at early
childhood stressors and then how people
do in school early stress has this
profound negative effect and so what can
be done it's actually very hard to do
anything nonetheless I'm a fan of this
guy universe virginia named eric tremor
who studies poverty and IQ and he's
found that people with grew up in
poverty have lower IQs and that's
because they live in such stress the
environmental influence on IQ is very
profound at the bottom and not so much
at the top end and so then he did
studies to find out what is it about
poverty that lowers IQ is that the
economic part is it the family part is
it the neighborhood part and so he tried
to disaggregate it all and found he
could not there was no instant one thing
no one lever that explained the
phenomenon it was the interplay of all
the different phenomena souter Kaymer
came up with this concept the gloomy
prospect we can't see down into the
effect of poverty because it's lost in
the gloomy prospect it's it's in the
interplay of things that are too complex
for us to understand so how do you deal
with a problem that is a gloomy prospect
well my answer would be you throw the
kitchen sink
you throw everything at it you don't
know what's causing the problem so you
try everything all at once you sort of
flood the zone and so to me the best
solution is Harlem Children's Zone type
projects where you've got schools you've
got pre-k you've got mentor programs
you've got Boys & Girls Clubs you're
just throwing everything at a geographic
spot because you really don't know
what's gonna solve it you just hope to
get a positive feedback cycle and that
happens to be expensive and Obama
promised to spread a lot of these Harlem
Children's Zone around the country
hasn't been so successful either because
they haven't raised the money to do it
or because they can't find a lot of
Geoffrey Canada's to do it and when
Canada came in he's the guy runs Harlem
Children's Zone he fired half the
teachers at the local schools it takes a
certain sort of person willing to do
that but to me that's the that's the
right thing to do just a lot of
different things in these targeted areas
including the pre-k program that the
president recently proposed which you
know I think Heckman is right skill but
gets skill learners learn early
investment pays off better than late
investment in a lot of the criticism
that you hear of President Obama there
amongst its critics there's this sense
of somehow that now that he's president
you know the country is going to hell
and before it used to be this you know
fantastic place and what are we gonna do
about I hear I was listening to a talk
show this morning and someone was
talking about you know how we need to
solve the deficit and he said one of the
founding fathers Thomas Jefferson said
that it's immoral to put you know for
people to pass on debt to their children
well Thomas Jefferson famously spent way
too much money bought all this you know
fancy wine and carpets and France and
stuff and died you know passing on a lot
of debt to his to his family so my
question is can you talk a little bit
about our tendency to idealize the past
and how that plays in with with politics
because even in your remarks it's true I
mean that's wonderful those are those
traits that you spoke of but I'm sure
that there's a lot of the stuff that's
going on today was also going back
different right I'm I personally don't
think it's useful to say that one
historic moral code is superior to
another I think each is a response to a
problem of a day and that they probably
each have advantages and disadvantages
and things to learn so I'm a little
hesitant that we're sliding into
depravity but I do think there were some
obviously there are some things we have
to teach Jefferson's day about slavery
you know kind of obvious things but I do
think it's also true that every
generation has a an incentive to spend
money on themselves and push costs onto
the future generation and no generation
has done it to such an extent until our
own and so why is that if you look at
Roosevelt even the depression when they
had plenty of excuse to spend a lot of
money there was a moral importance about
pushing it off debt off on the future
generations and that's a moral
abhorrence we have overcome and I think
it's because there's less of a
generational consciousness less of a
sense you're a piece of a long chain of
generations just one temporary piece I
think there's less of a sense of that
today and so there is this so here I'm
gonna say this because I think I can
over outrun many of the people in this
room so the average Medicare recipient
couple pays over the course of their
lifetime
eighty eight thousand dollars a year
into Medicare they take out over the
course of their lifetime two hundred
eighty eight thousand dollars so who
pays for that two hundred thousand
dollars college students and so that is
pushing a big burden off onto the future
and by the way I've raised this issue
with a zillion college students and so
why aren't you guys more upset about
this and they're like that's far in the
future it's not an issue I've never
found too many people who are really
upset and I've said you know you're
you're superseded by this extremely evil
baby boomer generation you should do
something about these people there that
I found no anger but I do think that is
while we are much better in most ways
and as I said we would never want to go
backwards in this way the sense of
obligation of the future I do think
we're more short-sighted I think of the
XL pipeline is possibly passing on some
naturalistic and environmental debt to
future generations can you comment on
that yeah well I disagree with you you
know I look at the that we have very few
real growth up opportunities right now
one of them I think is a good
immigration reform bill with more
skilled workers
another I think is the promise of shale
gas of cracking and I think when you
take a look at the benefits of fracking
which are not only much lower energy
costs much lower in fact much much lower
dependence on Middle Eastern energy
sources not gone obviously but much
lower and third a rejuvenation of
manufacturing especially in the Midwest
I think this is one of the truly good
things that's happened to our country in
the last 10 years the this explosion now
does it have to be managed responsibly
of course but I think a study was done
here at Yale if you take a look at the
cost of managing responsibly and which
are in the hundreds of millions of
dollars and the benefits which are in
the hundreds of billions of dollars to
me it's not a close call
and so I think we should have the Excel
the Excel pipeline in particular because
it's not as if the gas that's being made
in Canada is not going to be made it'll
be either shipped to China or go through
our pipeline so it's not an
environmental question it's just
question of who gets it and so I happen
to think this is one of the thing if
managed correctly could be a great boon
to the country thanks for being here
supposed to be and I think like some of
the other people will have some
questions today I thought of our
politicians and the president comes to
mind as someone who's written a few
books the other hand also has a frosty
relationship with the media you know
from this from his critics you know
there are other politicians that have
similar you can see trying to balance
how to play that right I mean we can
lose one person we've always seem to
sort of struggle with that my question
to you is the press has an explanatory
factor in our politicians our
self-promotion ilysm first one I never
blame anything on the press I think
we're pretty much perfect so well first
thing comes to mind is a again a
generational difference when George HW
Bush was running for president he was
raised in a culture where you didn't
talk about yourself
and so his campaign staff would beat up
on him they'd say you're running for
president talk about yourself and he'd
finally give a speech where he talked
about his talents and why they should be
elected president and his mother was
sense to live gave him a call and say
George you're talking about yourself
clam back up and so he he had that code
we've all overcome that now so now
people feel reasonably free to talk
about themselves Obama is I've met a lot
of self-confident people in my life but
my joke is the word Obama will be the
unit of measure for self confidence in
80 years so say he has 80 Obama's he's
under 20 Obama is he he is the most
self-confident person I've ever met in
my life
so when he says things in private that
are eye popping like self confident the
one that got out in public was something
he said to an aide Patrick Gaspard it's
was in their job interview he said I
want you know I'm a better speechwriter
than all my speech writers I have more
policy expertise than my policy advisers
and I'm a better political analyst than
my political analysts I would say if you
speak that way you have a reasonably
high degree of self-confidence although
I saw the and the wire today that he he
did say he's become more humble
as since he's been present a further
sign of his great self-confidence to say
them and but I just think even aside
from him who's in extraordinary case
they're in the business of branding
themselves like a lot of us it's not
unusual they're just in the extreme end
and so they're using the media to do
that to create the image of themselves
every meeting they go to it's about them
every conversation they have is about
them it's promoting the image and
they're surrounded by people who love
them I had an interview with somebody in
this administration we were talking and
you could hear the helicopter the
presidential helicopters whirring in the
lawn of the White House and he got up
interrupted the interview he looked out
the back window just to watch the
president's back go into the helicopter
because he just wanted that 15-second
view of the president and so I found
this in every White House they're in
love with the person they're in love and
if you're surrounded by that much love
it's hard not to be a little weird and
so they're all emotional freaks of one
sort or another and so I think that's
the major dynamic the effect I found the
media's had recently and this is just
one thing they're moving things the
media is done but it used to be when I
started or even up to about 2000 when
you are with a politician on the
campaign trail or just in most events
you could have an off-the-record private
conversation you drive around with them
in vans and you just shoot the breeze
like a normal person
now because of these things and the
ubiquity of cameras you can't have those
conversations they're always terrified
that something's gonna be filmed and
will wind up on YouTube and so the
transparency the technology has created
opaqueness for the politicians and that
has had I think a bad effect on their
just their ability to have a normal
conversation a couple times a day and so
that's that's one effect the other final
effect is that you know we're very
cynical and we're very negative toward
them and so they become combative and
and very touching
okay well thank mr. Brooks said it
appears as though we're gonna let this
up it's your own fault for being tall
I'm not sure
in fact I sort of doubt that this is
anything particularly new but it does
appear as though we're a distinct
political impasse in which we have two
parties that are unwilling to compromise
particular in the fiscal arena as
someone who sort of shares your the
state conservatory
and somehow it might take form is it
more likely that the Republican
coalition might sort of reform and be
perhaps willing to raise revenue or
would it be more likely that you know
maybe under Obama's leadership they
might be willing to make sort of common
sense sort of revenue decreasing like
raising this age of Social Security
retirement to 70 meet some basic moves
that the Democratic Party is unwilling
to touch well at the same time the
Republican Party to say is unwilling to
tax to $1 on Social Security and I've
read that those two things together
would make the problem solved such a
compromise isn't there's sort of
common-sense measures that I think sort
of the average American are willing to
take and yet the political gridlock is
unwilling to do I don't know how how you
see a solution taking shape where am i
come from well I used to think we would
just have a fiscal crisis and we get
serious about it and I remember asking
an economist in the White House a couple
years ago you know do you think we'll
solve our budget problem or would we
have some sort of national bankruptcy
he said no we'll have a bankruptcy and
then we'll get you know then we'll take
care of it
and so I remember I asked well how bad
will the fiscal crisis be we'll be like
Greece or decline and fall of the Roman
Empire and he said sort of in the middle
they're worse than Greece not as bad as
their own sort of stuck there in the
middle and so I used to think that I've
now been persuaded by some economists
that that doesn't necessarily need to
happen that we could just go on and on
and ever it'll never come to a crisis
moment it'll just be a slow slide into
complete insolvency without the crisis
action-forcing mechanism and so at that
point we either inflate our way out or
something but if you ask me honestly
I I say think you know as you suggest if
you went to anything tank whether it's
Brookings Institution of the American
Enterprise Institute
they have sensible plans to get us out
of this mess but do I see any
willingness on the part of the elected
politicians to undertake these things
like means-test Medicare raise a
consumption tax which i think would be a
good idea I really think all those
things of sufficient size are completely
off the table and I think there's
possible the possibility of creating a
short-term stasis so we sort of
stabilized it over ten years but that
doesn't solve the problem it just means
another year or 10 to 15 we get this
massive explosion and so I really see
very little chance or at least no sign
that we're about to get serious about
that and so I'm I'm a pessimist and the
final thing I'll say is I'm to the point
where I do not blame the politicians I
do think they are responding
intelligently to the incentives they are
being offered if you ask Americans
should Medicare be cut by a dime
seventy-five percent say no so how do
you expect the politicians to react do
you want to see tax increases on you
well you can tax the top one or two
percent but not me and so that those two
beliefs which are vastly held in a
bipartisan basis make it impossible
so until there's a coalition of leaders
to do a big massive education campaign
and actually ask for the sacrifice I
really don't see us solving it and
that's my you know my biggest national
worry so I'm not happy nope thank you
very much